early morning in Fulton Heath part of
the South London borough of Croydon
the people of Briggs stock Road are
going about their business this is an
ordinary high street shaped by a
generation of immigration 45% of the
community are from black and ethnic
minority backgrounds
now they are wrestling with another wave
of newcomers
amongst the shops and cafes is a
government hostel one of the first
places asylum seekers who've just
arrived in Britain are brought to
there's a constant flow of migrants and
their families they stay here just a few
days before being dispatched around the
country to wait for their applications
to be processed
most have so little English they are
unable to explain for themselves why
Britain should take them in this man
from Iraq has photographs to speak for
him enjoy
almost everyone is from Africa and the
Middle East
they all know claimants fleeing conflict
have a better chance of making it to
Europe something some of the migrants
are prepared to use to their advantage
trekking across Europe Muhammad man Lao
flew to London from Germany as a Syrian
he was guaranteed asylum there instead
he shows us with pride his application
to stay in Britain but as we discovered
the trainee architect says his
nationality makes him the envy of some
of his fellow hostel residents
some people the government house office
they are Assyrians
I don't know how maybe just say we are
Syrians maybe they give a youth to their
fake papers yeah just like that
so there are people staying in there now
yes they are not from Syria but are
pretending to be from Syria yeah yeah
where are they from from Morocco or from
from Egypt everywhere I probably
understand the Home Office says it has a
rigorous application process and carries
out language analysis where necessary
but concerns about who is living at the
hostel are shared by some in the
community greengrocer Mohamed Ali says
there should be more checks on the
temporary residence they gotta do
something
I don't had their gonna check him farmer
Terry just are you gonna say I'm a mite
if you do come here and say ah
you know me the beard but you can't
judge a book by its cover I mean an arm
here I'll be born and bred here I mean I
wouldn't want anything to happen to my
family I mean end it there you
understand do you feel sorry for them
yeah of course for you sorry for him I
mean I'm a Muslim as well when you see
people suffering if you got a heart you
feel for people and you get me you get
people there walk past and say no can I
take something do you mind if the arcs I
don't mind I'll give them
lack of interaction and the inability to
communicate makes some residents
naturally suspicious of the migrants
the woman's hairdressers is not where
they are likely to spend what little
money they have
Ross Messer says the whole issue of
immigration has reached a tipping point
you can't just keep letting everybody in
because there's just no it's just not
the room housing none of it none of it
it's just going to explode and how do
you mean it's going to explode what do
you mean well a few years ago we had the
riots in Croydon you're gonna start
saying maybe that again did you get a
sense sometimes yeah
I live in Croydon you can feel it all
the way around what do you feel the
frustration people feel frustrated that
all these people are coming over here
I'm coming over here what taking jobs
taking jobs the hospital the schools
schools are having to be built and these
people can only speak the language and
what's what's the answer do you think
close barriers close up down so people
can't eat
not really no 0:01 Gration we're
thankful that we've got lectures that
you have got a barber he's cutting my
hair
my mum and dad is still alive you know
them had been shot or bombed so if I was
to live that life I would do exactly the
same thing unlimited migration that
anybody if need be in their suffering
but what do you say to people who are in
this area and say look you can't have an
endless flood of migrants coming to
Britain because the schools and the
hospitals can't cope and that ultimately
you will lose the cultures and
traditions of the country and if English
is no longer the first language in in a
lot of areas and amongst a lot of people
the main language first language of
Britain will always be English that will
never change but multicultural is turned
multicultural the demographics have
changed life moves on you don't like it
in Britain as Jamaican to say come alter
or leave the man in the floor shop next
door to the hostel says it's the
migrants who should be moving on blaming
them for a downturn in his business a
lot of people are moved away from you
people used to be my regulars that don't
come around here anymore
after years of problems the current
crisis has done nothing to soften his
views how do you feel about having the
hostel on your doorstep it's not very
pleasant I didn't go stay with it I
don't have a choice well it's when the
filth is around you they're throwing
things around you've come in the morning
you're to clean the place up people
standing around here loitering doing
nothing it doesn't make a pleasant sight
but I guess they don't have anything to
do do they because they're in the
process of applying for asylum that
they're not doing anyone any harm
they're just standing
so far as that is there they're not
doing any trouble that is fine but once
there get either drinking and stuff and
then they start creating trouble that's
when the problem is and you say that
there are problems with my problem
drinking literally making a place
unpleasant
not always a welcome sight on the
streets if the migrants stay indoors
this is where they pass their time the
dining hall where people eat here this
is a place to eat we were given this
mobile phone footage taken inside the
brick stop Road hostel
is one each we know look the government
is obliged to provide accommodation for
everyone who claims asylum for the new
arrivals hoping for acceptance they have
some unwanted guests of their own
when we contacted the home office they
told us robust mechanisms are in place
to ensure high standards are met by
contractors who run the building
somewhere to sleep and something to eat
it may not be quite how they imagined
but this is the reality of the new
journey the migrants are on having
arrived in Britain a safer place every
place is this
I must continue my study I wants to look
to the future I'm in England I'm safe
just like that yeah
you